yeah welcome to this video new game
against only x I'm expecting okay
thinking maybe get a Slav but guy played
them some sloth-like set up before
instead we have a Ben Oni no it's a
modern benoni
yeah this night e 2 2 g-3 setup was
recently um features in this um playing
1d4 by last shunned off dumb i like this
idea playing the night there even before
playing f3 it's very similar to a
sammich but you're you're flexible but a
bit more flexible with your with your
other pieces so you don't necessarily
need to play a 3 in all cases but yeah
here I needed to of course he's no
threatening to take a form h4 and take
it so okay i reroute it the light to f2
and black normally goes for f5 in these
positions on Knight e5 and f5 probably
95 first night fer maybe
the idea of the smooth King edge one is
to at some point have the idea look g 1
and g 3 opening up the G file yeah this
is sometimes sometimes a possibility
what was amazed that you can play all
this in front of your king but it's it's
it's really possible ok mmmm wait wait
wait wait not not so quickly taking it's
not bad i'm pretty pretty sure but I
wonder what about f4 f4 this may be a
possibility to to wear to open up the
position even more f/4g for I take on f5
hmm i don't know maybe he's got them
g3 f/4g for takes a 5 g 3 looks very
weird ok I take and then f form on
Queenie seven I thought Bishop g4 would
be would be a good good option I hope
I'm right yeah he is playing this
instantly of course Oh Bishop d3
it's probably not much of a difference
yeah it said I saw that it's probably a
pawn sacrifice but I've got the light
squares I thought there should be
something Queen takes Queen takes Queen
takes Queen takes rook takes Bishop f5
takes a fall Neji for something like
this i'm attacking at four this was my
idea at least i hope that would be good
playing on the light squares i I'm not
so sure what are you thinking about I
think he needs to take it otherwise i
play rookie one end he's just it just
has an open king but maybe there are
some some move all the things that you
can do I know like take on c3 first or
something but otherwise Queen takes III
looks like the move you should play wow
yeah this looks completely out of this
world is there or maybe maybe there's
some some huge trickier k this is normal
what's the trick Knight f6 or some great
stuff I don't know I'm not sure how the
other one was was really terrible he
took he took lots of time but this looks
like like a disaster for black honestly
94
may look at the pieces every every
pieces is excellent so Bishop yeah this
looks good give this check first
open up lines 95 is the move and this is
so open so 95 now or says something
better yeah come on it must be must be
right
yeah I don't see when night c5 doesn't
seem to win
this doesn't really look like the right
move but I didn't see something else
maybe Bishop e6 wasn't wasn't the best
possible now I'm in this in this awkward
pin amazing
yeah I don't have a movements it's crazy
ah where did I spoil this
Jeff
I can just take this again resigns wow
this this hurts this really hurt wow man
this is fled out winning from right this
position here and I didn't find it add
this is this look good yeah but ok
alright it's always very very hurting
till you get this with the computer
because it shows you that you can win at
every move and you don't see it ok this
still sister still keeps an advantage at
least 25 m 25 engine just take c5 with
quite a big advantage what I did make
looks good yeah an idea I knew that 95
wasn't it wasn't the best move but this
was strong of course didn't take or
something under there are Queen III is
still a big edge
why this was just bad by me Wow with 40
extra seconds and yeah just um how on
earth can you not take on III I mean
this is yeah okay but then I'm stupid
and cannot win I mean you can play
everything every crap to be to be frank
about that I mean this is simply how can
you play Bishop g 6 cm in this position
after this it's clear that i'm attacking
with all pieces and black is just busted
I'm not what I play them in Bishop h6
screen f2 it's a it's like can play
everything not just what I did now queen
d fibers also also better but I've let's
let's just check quickly I mean what
kind of ghost he saw I mean I had an
idea here with this but I didn't think
that this is so terrible look at this
this was my idea so that I get get this
back and I have a very nice bishop on f5
but look at this position I mean
blackest black can just play this there
are the Queen's I exchanged you won't
maybe here you won't get mated or
something and in the game it's just just
a meeting attack the kind of position
where let's say you get 10 minutes on
the clock you win every game but okay I
lost my way yeah thanks for watching